The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
get started.
Why doesn't everyone go ahead
and take 10 more seconds on
this clicker question.
It should look familiar.
You were pretty split on this
question on Friday, so we're
hoping after learning a little
bit more about delta g of
formation, we have at
least one direction
that wins out here.
OK, great.
So now we're up to 85% of you,
and hopefully in just a minute
we'll be up to a 100%.
But if delta g of formation here
is less than zero, that
means we're talking about a
spontaneous reaction when we
form the compound.
So if it spontaneously forms the
compound, that must mean
that the compound is
going to be stable
relative to its elements.
So that's kind of the last thing
we went over in terms of
topics on Friday, and we'll
pick up right there today.
All right.
Here we have our notes for
today, so reminder exam 2 is
on Wednesday --
I don't think I need to
remind anyone of that.
But just please, don't come to
this room, make sure that you
go to Walker to take the exam.
And also if you have any
questions or you feel like
there's anything you don't
understand, I have office
hours today from 2 to
4 in my office.
Your TAs have also all moved
their office hours so they
fall before the exam.
So make sure you get any of
your questions addressed
before you're trying to
sit there and figure
it out in exam time.
All right, so today we're going
to pick up where we left
off on thermodynamics, so that
was talking about free energy
of formation.
After that we're going to talk
a little bit more about the
effect of temperature
on spontaneity.
We touched upon this on Friday,
but we're going to
formalize exactly in which cases
temperature can or can
not affect whether a reaction
is spontaneous or
non-spontaneous.
Then we're going to look a
little bit into thermodynamics
and biological systems.
Two examples that I wanted to
talk about were ATP coupled
reactions -- those are very
important in biology.
And also, thinking about the
idea of hydrogen bonding,
we're going to combine our
thoughts on bond enthalpies,
and also our ideas of bonding
that we had from thinking
about covalent and
ionic bonds.
All right, so let's finish
up first with
free energy of formation.
So as 85% of you just told me,
when we have a case where
delta g of formation is less
than zero, what we're talking
about here is a compound that
is thermodynamically stable
relative to its elements.
So that means we know the
inverse as well, which is when
we're talking about a case where
delta g is now greater
than zero, the compound is going
to be thermodynamically
unstable relative
to its elements.
So any time you're looking at
delta g of formation, just
remember to think about this
is just the delta g of a
reaction where you're
forming a compound.
So it should make sense that if
it's negative, it's going
to be spontaneous and you're
going to have a stable
compound here.
So we could look at any number
of examples, really we could
pick any compound to look at,
but up on the screen here I'm
just putting the compound, the
formation of benzene, we've
looked at benzene a lot.
So benzene has a delta
g of formation of 124
kilojoules per mole.
Is benzene stable or unstable
compared to its elements?
I can't really tell the
difference between stable and
unstable when you say it,
so everyone start at
the same time, go.
STUDENT: Unstable.
PROFESSOR: OK, excellent.
Benzene is unstable compared
to its elements.
So that means the reverse
reaction here is going to be
stable -- or the reverse
reaction is going to be
spontaneous where we
actually have the
decomposition of benzene.
So when we're seeing this, when
we're seeing that the
reverse reaction is spontaneous,
a question that
might immediately come to us is
well, why did we just spend
all the time talking about
benzene because clearly
benzene's just going to
break down, right.
Why do we form benzene and not
have it immediately decompose
into its elements.
Thermodynamically that is what
should happen and it is what
does happen, but the reality
is that this reaction, this
decomposition of benzene is
actually very, very slow.
It's so slow that, you know we
use benzene all the time in
organic reactions, we don't see
it break down even when we
heat it up, is because
even though this is
thermodynamically a
non-spontaneous reaction to
form benzene, it's very slow for
the actual decomposition
of benzene to occur.
So this is just another case,
and I'll keep saying this, and
when Professor Drennan starts
talking about kinetics, she'll
keep repeating this as well.
What we want to keep in mind
is that delta g tells us
whether a reaction will happen
or whether it won't happen.
It tells us absolutely nothing
about how long it takes for
that reaction to happen.
It tells us nothing about the
rate of the reaction.
We'll keep seeing examples of
this, so hopefully no one will
be confused by the time
we do get to kinetics.
So if we're talking about
calculating delta g for any
reaction, now we actually have
several ways to do it.
The first way is very analogous
to thinking about
delta h for the reaction.
We can just look up a
table where we have
delta g as a formation.
So we can take the sum of the
delta g of formation of the
products, and subtract from it
the delta g of formation of
the reactants.
We also have another way if
maybe we don't have that
information available to us.
We can also take a look at using
this reaction or this
equation right here, which is
telling us that delta g of a
reaction is equal to the
change in enthalpy
minus t delta s.
So that tends to be very
helpful, especially when we
want to take into consideration
temperature.
So let's take into consideration
We've done this a little bit so
far, but let's really take
a look at some reactions where
temperature's going to make a
big difference.
So the reaction we're going
to look at here is the
decomposition of sodium
bicarbonate, or sodium bicarb
here, and it decomposes it into
sodium carbonate, plus c
o 2, carbon dioxide,
and water.
So we can think about
calculating that delta g of
this reaction.
I'll tell you that the change in
enthalpy, this is actually
an endothermic reaction.
It requires heat.
It's plus 135 .
6 kilojoules per mole.
So let's go to a clicker
question and I want you to
pick out from several choices
which of the changes in
entropy seem reasonable
to you here.
So what would you predict
the delta s for
this reaction to be?
All right, let's do 10
more seconds on that.
OK, so we've got the majority,
but not everyone.
So let's take a look at why this
is the correct answer,
that it should be plus 0.334 .
If we're going from 2 moles of
solid, to 1 mole of solid,
plus 2 moles of gas, are
we increasing or
decreasing the disorder?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We're increasing
the disorder.
If we're getting to a more
disordered state, then we're
going to have a positive
change in entropy.
We're going to increase
the disorder.
The only one with a positive
delta s is this choice here.
So if we switch back to our
notes, we can see that, in
fact, so what we see is that
it's 0.334 kilojoules per k
per mole is our delta s, so we
can go ahead and calculate our
delta g for the reaction,
so we're just plugging
in our delta h.
So our delta h is 135 .
6.
And we're talking about to start
with let's talk about
room temperature.
So 298 k times 0.334 .
So what we end up having for the
delta g of our reaction is
that its 36 .
1 kilojoules per mole.
So this is at room
temperature.
So is our reaction spontaneous
or non-spontaneous at room
temperature?
STUDENT: Non-spontaneous.
PROFESSOR: Non-spontaneous.
All right, but let's take
a look at a different
temperature.
For example, let's look
at baking temperature.
So if we think about baking
cookies, we maybe bake them at
350 degrees fahrenheit, so that
would be 450 kelvin --
our ovens are usually set to
fahrenheit and not kelvin.
So if we think about this
reaction that this
temperature, first of all let
me point out why we would be
talking about baking
cookies for this
particular reaction here.
Does anyone know what another
name for sodium bicarb is?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
just baking soda.
So this is the reaction that
causes your cookies or your
cakes to actually rise.
So we're producing gas here, and
when we're producing that
gas when this sodium bicarb
decomposes, we're forming
these pockets of gas
in our baked goods.
So if we bake our cookies at
room temperature, obviously,
they don't bake and they also
don't rise because the sodium
bicarb, clearly it was
non-spontaneous at room
temperature, this reaction
just doesn't happen.
But if we take a look at baking
temperature now, we're
going to plug in this new
temperature, which is 450 k,
and plug this into our
delta g reaction.
What we find is now our delta
g for the reaction
is negative 14 .
7 kilojoules per mole.
So in this case, we are dealing
with a spontaneous
reaction, which is good, because
this means that when
we put our cookies in and we
turn it to 350 fahrenheit or
450 k, the baking soda will
decompose and we'll got our
cookies to rise a little bit.
All right, so one thing that I
want you to notice when we
were talking about the case
with the decomposition of
sodium bicarb is that the delta
h for that reaction and
the delta s, they both
had the same sign.
And something that you can keep
in mind in general is any
time that both delta h and delta
s have the same sign,
it's actually possible to switch
from spontaneous to
non-spontaneous or vice versa
just by changing the
temperature of the reaction.
And we can think about
this graphically.
If we assume that delta h and
delta s are independent of
temperature, which is a good
assumption to a first
approximation, in this case we
find that the delta g of the
reaction is the linear function
of the temperature.
So that means we can go ahead
and graph what we saw for the
case of baking soda.
So our first point here was
that we saw at room
temperature, about 298 k, the
delta g was positive, it was
36 kilojoules per mole.
We also saw that once we
heated it up to baking
temperature, we actually had the
delta g now at negative 15
kilojoules per mole.
So since this is linear, we can
actually draw a straight
line right through here, and
we can think about the fact
that we have this temperature
here where anything below this
temperature has a positive delta
g, and anything above
this temperature is going to
have a negative delta g.
And let's actually think about
the fact that this is a line
and see what our slope and our
y-intercept is going to mean.
We can say that delta g is equal
to negative delta s t
plus delta h, if we want to put
it in the formation of the
equation for line.
So what this tells us is that
our slope is going to be
negative delta s here, and
if we think about our
y-intercept, that's going to be
the change in enthalpy for
the reaction.
So again, what I want to point
out is that any time we're at
a temperature that's lower
than this change in
temperature here, we're going
to find that delta g is
greater than zero, and we're
going to be dealing with a
non-spontaneous reaction.
However, if we move our
temperature up and up and up
so we go across the graph this
way, eventually we'll hit a
point where if we're above that
temperature, we'll find
that delta g is less than
zero, and now we have a
spontaneous reaction.
So we can actually think about
what this temperature is.
We can call this T star.
This is the temperature at which
our reaction switches,
whether it's spontaneous
or non-spontaneous.
And if you're thinking about
trying to get a reaction to
go, it's very important to be
able to calculate what this
temperature is.
A lot of times in organic
chemistry laboratories, they
need to heat up reactions --
part of why they do that is
kinetics, but the other part is
sometimes they need to make
a reaction go from being
non-spontaneous to
spontaneous.
So let's think about how to
calculate T star or this
change in temperature.
So we're talking about this
threshold temperature, so
we're talking about where delta
g is going to be equal
to zero, because if we set delta
g equal to zero, we know
that anything on one side of
that temperature is going to
be spontaneous, and the other
side is going to be
non-spontaneous.
So if we do this, we can just
rewrite our reaction, delta g
equals delta h minus t delta s,
and let's plug in our zero
for delta g there, and now
rearrange our reaction so that
we're talking about this
threshold temperature.
So that T star is just going to
be equal to the change in
enthalpy divided by the
change in entropy.
So it's very easy for us to
calculate, so let's go ahead
and do this for the case
with baking soda.
And for baking soda what we saw
was that delta h was 136
kilojoules per mole, and the
change in entropy was 0.334
kilojoules per k mole.
And that means if we do that
simple division, then what we
end up as our temperature
star is 406 kelvin.
So basically, what this tells us
is if we tried to bake our
cookies below 406 kelvin they
would not rise, if we bake
them above 406 kelvin they
will rise because this
reaction is now spontaneous.
All right, so this was a case
where we had seen that the
delta h and the delta s both
had a positive value.
But let's take a look at what
happens when now delta h and
delta s are both negative.
So we can think about this just
by plotting it on our
graph again -- we don't have
actual values, but we can
think about what the
sign should be.
So if we talk about our zero
point where temperature is
absolute zero, if we have a
positive, or excuse me, if we
have a negative delta h now
and we're at temperature
equals zero, what is delta
g going to be?
Negative or positive?
Yeah, it's going
to be negative.
So if we have negative delta h
and we're at temperature of
zero, our s term completely
falls out, so we're definitely
going to start with a
negative delta g.
As we increase the temperature
higher and higher, at some
point that delta s term is going
to become greater than
our delta h term, so at some
point we're going to flip to
where the reaction has now
a positive delta g.
So you can draw this into your
graphs in your notes where
we're going to start, in this
case if delta g is negative
where delta g starts negative,
and then when it hits that
threshold temperature,
anything above that
temperature is going
to be positive.
So if we had actual numbers we
could plug those into our
graph, but we should be able to
understand what the general
trend is going to be even in a
hypothetical case where we're
just dealing with is it positive
or is it negative.
So what we see is that below
this temperature, we have a
spontaneous reaction, and above
this temperature we have
a non-spontaneous reaction.
That was flipped from the case
where we had delta h and delta
s both be positive.
All right, so let's actually
summarize what all of our four
different scenarios could be
if we're dealing with delta
h's and delta s's.
So to start with, why don't you
tell me what you think if
we have a reaction where we have
a negative delta h and we
have a positive delta s, do you
think that this will be a
reaction that's never
spontaneous, always
spontaneous, or will this be one
of these cases where the
spontaneity depends
on temperature?
All right, let's take 10
more seconds on this.
OK, great.
So most of you got it.
So let's go back to the slides
and think a little bit about
why this is.
So, this case is always
spontaneous, because in this
case we have a negative delta
h, which contributes to a
negative delta g, and a positive
delta s, but since
the equation says minus t delta
s, that means a positive
delta s is also going
to contribute to a
negative delta g.
So regardless of what the
temperature is, we're going to
have a spontaneous reaction.
So we say this is always
spontaneous -- delta g is less
than zero at all temperatures.
All right.
So let's look at the reverse
case here where delta h is now
greater than zero, and delta
s is less than zero.
Is this always, never, or
sometimes spontaneous?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Nope.
So, this is going to be never
spontaneous in this case.
So for the same reason, because
delta h is greater
than zero, that contributes to
a positive delta g, and delta
s being negative also
contributes to a
positive delta g.
So we'll say again, that this
delta g is greater than zero
at all temperatures.
All right, so now we have a case
where delta h is greater
than zero and delta s is greater
than zero as well.
Is this going to be always,
never, or sometimes
spontaneous?
STUDENT: Sometimes.
PROFESSOR: Sometimes, good.
So, even before thinking, you
can just remember if the signs
are the same, we can
have a dependence
on temperature here.
So what we find is that this
is sometimes spontaneous.
So we can think about
when this happens.
Would it be when the actual
temperature is greater or less
than that threshold
temperature?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, so I
heard a lot of people say
greater than.
It's greater than, because when
it's greater than that
threshold temperature, that
means that the delta s term is
the one that's going to actually
sort of take over,
it's going to be at some point
greater than the delta h term.
The delta h is going to be
making the delta g positive.
That means it would make it
non-spontaneous, but once
delta s gets large enough,
that's going to override, and
now we're going to have a
negative delta g only when the
temperature is above that
threshold temperature.
So similarly, when we see that
delta h is negative and delta
s is negative, this is also
going to be sometimes
spontaneous, and specifically,
it will be spontaneous or
delta g will be less than 0 when
the temperature is less
than that threshold
temperature.
All right, so you should be able
to look at any situation
where you have or you figure
out or you calculate the
enthalpy and the enthropy change
in the reaction, and
you should right away, before
doing any calculations, be
able to know is this always
spontaneous, is this never
spontaneous, or is this
something where I'm going to
need to really take
temperature into
consideration.
And if I do, you can actually
calculate what that
temperature is going to
be where you flip from
spontaneous to non-spontaneous
or vice versa.
All right, so shifting gears a
little bit, let's take a look
at a few examples where it's
important to think about
thermodynamics and biological
systems.
So there's two things I
particularly want to focus on.
So the first is the idea of
ATP coupled reactions.
So this is really important,
because when we're talking
about biological reactions, a
lot of the reactions that take
place in our body are actually
non-spontaneous, so
energetically we figure that the
delta g for this reaction
is actually positive.
So I just show a schematic
biological reaction here where
we have some molecule that's
broken up into
two building blocks.
So let's say, for example,
this has a delta g that's
greater than zero.
We need to think about how it is
that our body can actually
make this reaction happen.
And the way that it does this
is that it takes the
hydrolysis of ATP, and the
hydrolysis of ATP is what's
called that it's coupled to this
non-spontaneous reaction.
And when you have a spontaneous
reaction coupled
to a non-spontaneous reaction,
you can potentially drive the
reaction in the forward
direction.
Remember the hydrolysis of ATP
is spontaneous, so what we're
doing in this case is we're
taking a spontaneous reaction
where we give off energy, and
we're coupling it to a
non-spontaneous reaction
that requires energy.
So what we will hope is when
we add up the total energy
changes between these two
reactions, if the sum of those
two is a negative delta g total,
now we can have this
whole process move in the
forward direction.
So let's take a look at thinking
about what we can do
in terms of a coupled
reaction.
The first thing we need to do if
we're thinking about using
the hydrolysis of ATP is
actually calculate what the
delta g for the reaction of
ATP hydrolysis is, and I
picked 310 kelvin because
that's the
temperature of our bodies.
So again, this reaction is
taking adenosine triphosphate
that has three phosphate groups
and hydrolyzing it, so
reacting it with water
to form ADP plus
phosphate plus acid here.
So I'll tell you that the delta
h of this reaction is
negative 24 kilojoules
per mole.
This is what we actually
calculated in class on Friday.
And that the delta s is plus 22
joules per k, per mole, so
we can go ahead and calculate
what this delta g is here.
So the delta g of this overall
reaction is just going to be,
of course, delta h minus t delta
s, and our delta h is
minus 24 kilojoules per mole,
and we'll subtract 310
kelvin times 0 .
022 kilojoules over k mole.
So if we do this, what we end
up getting is a delta g of
negative 31 kilojoules
per mole of ATP.
All right, so again, this is
good, we got a negative
number, that's what
we were expecting.
So that means that we will have
energy available to use
if we hydrolyize ATP
and couple it to
another reaction here.
So what we saw for our
delta g, negative 31
kilojoules per mole.
All right, so let's talk about
a reaction that is a ATP
coupled reaction, and there's
just tons of examples of this
in our body.
One I picked because it has to
do with glucose, which we have
talked so much about, is the
conversion of glucose to
glucose 6 p.
So 6 p -- p just stands for a
phosphate group here, so what
we're doing is taking, if we
numbered the glucose carbons,
this would be carbon number
six, and we're putting a
phosphate group on carbon
number six.
So first of all, why would our
body need to do this reaction?
It turns out that glucose,
we know that we
use glucose for energy.
Glucose is somewhat apolar, so
it can actually move in and
out of our cells, because
our cell walls,
those are very greasy.
So what we're actually doing
here is we're putting a
charged molecule onto
the glucose.
There's two negative charges in
a phosphate group, this is
going to make sure that
our glucose is now
it's very polar molecule.
And now that we have a very
polar molecule, we're not
going to be able to have
the glucose move in
and out of the cell.
So we keep it in our cell
by putting this
phosphate group on it.
That's why we want to do this
reaction, but let's think
about the energy of
actually doing it.
And it turns out that this
requires energy.
The delta g for this reaction
is 17 kilojoules per mole.
All right, so that could be a
problem if our body had not
come up with a way to solve it,
which it has, and what it
actually does is it couples this
reaction here with the
conversion of ATP into ADP.
And we just calculated that that
has a delta g of negative
31 kilojoules per mole.
So this means we can think about
delta g total, and by
total we mean of this overall
process here.
So that's just equal to 17,
and we're adding it to the
other delta g, which
is negative 31.
So we get an overall delta g for
this process of negative
14 kilojoules per mole.
All right, so that's one really
simple example just to
illustrate to you how these ATP
coupled reactions work.
Some ATP coupled reactions
require one molar equivalent
of ATP, some require
a lot more.
But essentially, the
idea is the same.
We have this reaction that's
energetically unfavorable that
we couple with an
energetically favorable reaction.
So, quite literally, this is
what we mean when we talk
about ATP as being the energy
currency for the cell.
We spend some ATP in order to
get these non-spontaneous
reactions to go.
All right, so I also want to
talk to a little bit about
hydrogen bonding.
This also is a topic that deals
with the thermodynamics,
and it also is related to the
ideas that we talked about
before in terms of
thinking about
different types of bonds.
So if we talk about a hydrogen
bond, a hydrogen bond, first I
just want to be really clear,
is not a covalent bond.
So this h x bond here is a
covalent bond, this is not a
hydrogen bond.
But a hydrogen bond can form
when you have a partial
positive on a hydrogen, and
you have what's called a
hydrogen bond donor atom, which
has a partial negative
on it, and also has
a lone pair.
Typically this y atom will be
on a separate molecule.
And what happens is you have
that Coulombic attraction
between the partial positive
on the hydrogen and the
partial negative on this
hydrogen bond donor atom.
So what you form between them is
a hydrogen bond, and you'll
notice that I drew it
as a dashed line.
H bonds or hydrogen bonds are
drawn either as dashed lines
or as dotted lines, and
they're done so to
differentiate them from covalent
bonds, which we draw
with this straight line here.
So let's think about what
can form hydrogen bonds.
First of all, there's a
requirement for what this h x
bond can be.
It has to be a really
electronegative atom in this x
here, because we need to we
need to form that partial
positive on the hydrogen, which
means that the atom that
it's covalentally bonded to
needs to be pulling away some
of that electron density from
the hydrogen, such that we
have a delta positive
on a hydrogen atom.
Similarly, the same atoms are
what can be the y here, so it
can either be a nitrogen or
an oxygen or a fluorine.
So these are the only
hydrogen bond donors
that can form h bonds.
And we can think about the
reason for this and the reason
is pretty straightforward.
We need to have a small atom,
but it also needs to be really
electronegative.
This should make sense because
we need to have this partial
negative charge here to have
that Coulomb attraction.
And the other requirement is
that we definitely need to
have that lone pair of electrons
so it can actually
interact in this hydrogen
bond here.
So let's take a look at an
example of a hydrogen bond,
and that's between two
water molecules.
So let's go ahead and re-draw
our water molecules -- they're
just kind of randomly
oriented there.
But let's re-draw them as if
they were going to have a
hydrogen bond between them.
And one thing I want to point
out about hydrogen bonds is
that they're strongest when you
actually have all three
atoms in a straight line like
this, because it keeps the
dipoles the strongest, so the
partial positive here and the
partial negative here
can interact.
So let's re-draw our water
molecules like that.
So we have our first water
molecule here, and let's say
we're going to be talking about
this hydrogen in terms
of hydrogen bonding.
Obviously, we have four
hydrogens up there that can
take place or take part in h
bonding, but we're just going
to focus on this one here.
So that means we want our
straight line to be something
like this to our
second oxygen.
So let's draw the hydrogens on
this water molecule as well.
All right, so thinking about
what the Lewis structure of
water is, how many lone
pairs do we have
on this oxygen here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Two lone
pairs, great.
So let's draw those in,
and let's draw these
lone pairs in as well.
All right, and we're going to
be talking about these two
atoms in terms of our hydrogen
bond, so does this have a
delta plus or a delta
negative on it?
Delta plus.
So this is a polar bond here,
this o h bond, so we have a
delta plus on our hydrogen, and
we have a delta minus on
our oxygen.
So these also have delta
plusses, of course, and this
also has a delta minus.
So because these two can
interact and they're lined up
to do so, what we can do is we
can draw a hydrogen bond right
in between this hydrogen and
this oxygen atom here.
So again, I pointed out that,
in fact, hydrogen bonds are
not as strong as
covalent bonds.
Since they're not as strong, if
you remember thinking about
the relationship between bond
strength and bond length,
would you expect a hydrogen bond
to be longer or shorter
than a covalent bond?
STUDENT: Longer.
PROFESSOR: Good, OK, it
should be longer here.
So this is our longer bond
because it's our weaker bond.
They're not held together
as tightly.
All right, so this is an example
of an intermolecular
hydrogen bond, it's between
two different molecules.
Hopefully, you can also see that
if we're focusing on any
single one water molecule, we
could also form hydrogen bonds
between other water molecules
with either of these two
hydrogens as well, and also with
our other lone pair here.
So any water molecule can
actually form four different
hydrogen bonds.
All right, so let's talk a
little bit about these
hydrogen bonds in terms of their
bond enthalpies here.
I said that they were weaker
than covalent bonds, so let's
look at a few comparisons
here.
So we can look at an h o
hydrogen bond versus an h o
covalent bond.
And what we find is that the
bond enthalpies in kilojoules
per mole, it's 20 kilojoules per
mole for a hydrogen bond
versus 463 kilojoules per mole
for a covalent bond.
So we're not talking about
just a little bit weaker,
we're talking about much,
much weaker for the
hydrogen bonds here.
Similarly, if we look at
nitrogen, for nitrogen
hydrogen bonds, if we have an
o h bound to a nitrogen,
that's 29 kilojoules per mole.
If it's an n h hydrogen bound
to a nitrogen, that's 14
kilojoules per mole, and if
we're talking about an h n
covalent bond, now we're
talking about 388
kilojoules per mole.
All right, so again what we see
in these cases is that the
hydrogen bonds are much,
much weaker.
They tend to be as low as 5% of
what the covalent bond is,
so this is actually much weaker
than any kinds of bonds
we have within molecules, but
it's also the strongest type
of bond that we can
have between
two different molecules.
And one thing that you find as
in the case of water, is when
you have lots of hydrogen bonds
between molecules it
changes the property of, for
example, water here.
It makes the boiling point much,
much higher than you
might expect if you looked at
the other properties, because
you have to actually break apart
all of these individual
hydrogen bonds, and even though
it's not that much
energy for one individual
hydrogen bond, once you get a
huge number of hydrogen bonds,
you're talking about huge
energies here.
So let's look at some examples
of where we see hydrogen bonds
in biological processes.
First thinking about proteins,
they're absolutely hugely
important in proteins.
And in proteins, we're talking
about a molecule that's so
large that you don't just see
h bonds in between two
different molecules, what you
actually see is what's called
intramolecular hydrogen bonding,
so hydrogen bonding
within the protein
molecule itself.
And hydrogen bonding is
incredibly important, it, in
fact, is the shape of a protein,
which I'm just
showing an example here, histone
deacetylase, and the
histone deacetylase molecule
actually has just countless
hydrogen bonds in here, and
the hydrogen bonds largely
govern the shape of
the molecule.
So, if you're thinking about any
protein that has a shape,
so for example, we see these
ribbon structures here,
they're called alpha helices,
you can see some arrows, which
are just like a sheet structure
or beta sheets, that
actual shape is stabilized and
formed in the first place by
just many, many hydrogen bonds
within the protein being in a
correct orientation that allows
for this particular
shape to be stabilized.
And we know that shape is so
important when we're talking
about proteins, and that's
because the actual shape of
the protein governs the
interaction with other
proteins or other
small molecules.
The shape of the protein is
very important in terms of
positioning the specific atoms
that are involved in the
chemistry that the enzyme
carries out being in the
correct position.
So hydrogen bonds are very
important in terms of proteins.
We can also think of them
in terms of sugars or
polysaccharides.
This is a nice dramatic example,
thinking about the
structure of a protein is a
very microscopic way of
thinking about hydrogen
bonding.
If we want to take it to the
macroscopic level, we can talk
about h bonding in trees.
So if we're talking about trees,
trees are made up -- a
major part of a tree is the
polysaccharide cellulose.
So that's shown right here.
Cellulose is a chain of glucose
molecules linked together.
It can be as many as 1,000 or
more glucose molecules linked
together covalentally.
But what actually happens to
those individual chains is
that if you look at this picture
here, all those dotted
lines are actually
hydrogen bonds.
So the individual molecules are
in a much larger chain of
hydrogen bonded molecules and
they're incredibly rigid.
You have so many hydrogen bonds
that now it takes a huge
amount of energy to break
all of these.
So that accounts for
why wood is such
a hard, solid material.
And also, I mean for any plant,
and tree is the most
dramatic, the structure of
a tree, the macroscopic
structure, can be explained
by hydrogen bonding.
It's hydrogen bonds that keep
all of those molecules
together in the forest
and in trees.
All right.
So, that's proteins, that
thinking about sugars.
We can also talk about
the importance of
hydrogen bonding in DNA.
So if you think about the
characteristic DNA double
helix, hydrogen bonds, we have
in a double helix we have two
strands of DNA that you can
see are intertwined here.
And those two strands are
actually held together by
hydrogen bonding.
So specifically, it's hydrogen
bonding between what are
called complimentary bases
within the DNA.
So, for example, if we look at
guanine and cytosine here, you
can see that there's several
places, when they're lined up
like this, where we can
have hydrogen bonds.
So in terms of thinking about
how these two molecules are
lined up, how many h bonds
would you expect
between these two bases?
Yeah, so it's lined up
that there are three
that can form here.
So we have an o h hydrogen bond,
an h n, and then an h o
hydrogen bond that can form.
So the other side of
complimentary based pairs are
AT base pairs, and if you look
at the way these are lined up
here, how many hydrogen
bonds can form between
A and T base pairs?
Yup, so it it's two that
we can form here.
We have one between the h o, one
between the n h, and you
see that we've lost this
nitrogen, this n h group here,
and first of all this would be
too far apart anyway for
hydrogen bond, but we can't have
a hydrogen bond form when
we have a carbon h.
Remember, it has to either be
a nitrogen or an oxygen or a
fluorine because those are the
atoms that are going to pull
away enough electron density
from the hydrogen to give it a
partial positive charge
that it needs.
So in terms of thinking about
DNA, this is a really neat
case to consider the actual
thermodynamics or the bond
enthalpies of the hydrogen
bonds, because, of course,
does not always stay in it's
double helix -- when we're
talking about transcription, we
actually need to unzip or
separate this helix into its
two strands, so each
individual strand
can be copied.
So it's really important that
hydrogen bonds are strong
enough to hold the DNA double
strand together, but that
they're not so strong that when
you actually pull the
hydrogen bonds apart to open up
the double strand, that you
actually, you don't want to
break all of a covalent bonds
in DNA as well.
All right, so that's all we're
going to say in terms of
thinking about thermodynamics
and biological systems.
Hold on a sec, we have
plenty of time left.
I want to go over a few
clicker questions.
I didn't want to give you too
long set of notes, because
we're switching over to
Professor Drennan's going to
start lecturing on Friday, so
I thought maybe I shouldn't
have to have her finish
up with my notes.
So, Professor Drennan will
continue talking about
thermodynamics and thinking
about equilibrium, and then
she'll transition that into
talking about kinetics.
So that's actually what's going
to start happening after
the exam on Wednesday.
But let's take a look, since we
do you have a little bit of
time left, at a few clicker
questions just to make sure
everyone has caught what
we've gone over so far.
And a few reviews for the exam,
and I will have this
clicker question or one of the
ones following, be a clicker
question quiz, so make sure you
are still answering these
questions here.
So the first one covers what we
went over today, so I want
you to tell me and try to not
look back in your notes for
this, for a reaction where you
have a positive enthalpy and a
negative entropy change, would
you expect this reaction to be
never, always, or sometimes
spontaneous?
So let's take 10 seconds
on that, that
should be pretty fast.
OK, excellent.
90% is very good.
So this should never be
spontaneous, because we both
have the entropy and the
enthalpy term contributing to
a positive delta g.
All right, let's shift gears to
a couple of questions that
are review for the exam.
So hopefully, these
will all be very
straightforward for you now.
So I want you to think about
bond lengths here, and tell me
which molecule contains the
shorter nitrogen oxygen bond.
So, we're comparing n o minus
1, and n o 2 minus 1.
So if you wanted to get started
on this problem,
what's the first thing
you should do?
Yeah, draw some Lewis
structures.
So that might be a good
place to start in
thinking about this.
So I'll do that up here as well,
but don't look if you
want to try it on your own.
Remember, the quiz points
come for answering, not
for getting it right.
So try doing it on
your own here.
All right, let's go ahead
and take 10 more
seconds on this one.
OK, hold on.
Don't show the correct answer.
You know we're going to re-poll
and give you a little
bit more time to see if we
come to a consensus here.
So let's take another 30 seconds
or so on this while I
finish drawing these up here.
OK, good.
So we've got 81% have it correct
that in the n o minus
1 bond here, this is going
to be a double bond.
STUDENT: What if [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
It would be a double
bond here.
So, if you follow just the Lewis
structure rules, and you
go ahead, you'll find that we
end up having four bonding
electrons available.
So you can just go ahead and
plug those in, and you end up
with this many left.
If we had a triple bond, then
we would end up having more
bonding -- or we would end up
using more electrons than we
have available for
bonding here.
All right, so we have a double
bond in the case of n o.
What is this bond that
we have here?
Yup, so it's actually a 1 .
5 bond.
What is this bond that
we have here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right,
so we have two 1 .
5 bonds in this case, how
come these are 1.
5 and not, for example,
a double bond?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Great, so
that's the key.
Even though we have double
bonds in each of these
structures, in this case here,
we have resonance, so it's
turns out to be, in
fact, two 1 .
5 bonds.
So since this is the double
bond, it's going to be the
stronger bond.
Since it's the stronger bond,
it's also going to be the
shorter bond.
So make sure you can make those
relationships between
bond strength and bond length
and thinking about if you have
resonance or you don't
have resonance in
a particular situation.
All right, let's try one more
clicker question here.
We'll have this be the
last one for you.
So this is one that hopefully
you'll all get right, because
we've gone over this again and
again both in class and
recitation.
So let's talk about the
hybridization of the specific
carbon and oxygen atoms in ATP,
so I want you to go ahead
and tell me what these
hyrbridizations are
for these two atoms.
OK, let's take 10 more seconds
here, get those
final answers in.
OK, good, so 83% of
you got this.
Let's take a look at why.
So carbon a is bonded to three
things, but it is bonded to no
lone pairs, so we need to have
it be three hybrid orbitals,
so it's s p 2.
And oxygen is bonded to two
atoms plus two lone paris.
So we need four hybrid
orbitals or s p 3.
All right, so this was your quiz
question, so as long as
you answered it, you got your
quiz points for today.
And you can get going a little
bit early today and finish
studying for this exam.